coming to the GSB I knew that I was
going to be surrounded by people who
were incredibly passionate about the
spaces that they were in but one thing
that's really surprised me in a good way
is just how much so people have clear
visions of what they want to do the
level of impact they want to have in the
world the Asian business Student
Association also known as Absa is an
organization on campus that brings
together people of Asian descent come
from Asia or just have a general
interest in Asian culture or potentially
working in Asia in the future we seek to
provide social and advocacy and
professional events for folks from all
over the Asian diaspora whether
International or domestic students in
college I was not very involved with AI
communities because I didn't want to be
othered or be seen as different but here
at the GSB everyone really comes
together so that we have a stronger
sense of voice and also a unified voice
to raise awareness of the challenges
that the AAP Community is going through
here it's been really inspiring to meet
people who are so proud of their culture
and really have the space to share and
kind of talk about the aspects of their
childhood and culture that are most
important to them Asia is so big there's
so many countries cultures languages
that are kind of been captured within it
I think one of the things that's really
interesting is even though there are so
many different subc communities there's
always these little things that you can
relate to others on whether that's
having names that people are sometimes
less familiar with or maybe difficult to
pronounce
or certain foods and memories that we
have associated with our Cuisines or
this understanding of what it's like to
speak another language and maybe have
grown up speaking a different language
I'm really proud that here at ABA we
really try and include folks from all
different backgrounds and to create
events that are inclusive to everyone
and also to have advocacy on the behalf
of aapi folks one of the things I'm
excited about within this community is
really getting a chance to foster a
deeper sense ensive Community within
South Asians here at the GSB so last
year was the first year of the South
Asian business Students Association or
sabsa which falls under the Absa
umbrella but really gives a chance for
people that identify as South Asian to
connect with each other and that's
really been a community where a lot of
my closest friends have come from I
think one piece of advice I would give
to prospective applicants is really lean
into who you are embrace your identity
Embrace what makes you special and
unique and interesting and bring that to
the Forefront instead of trying to shift
yourself into this other idea or version
of you that isn't as true to who you are
first and foremost just apply and then I
think secondly I would advise folks to
really think about their story and what
really is driving them to apply to
Stanford to those coming to the GSB that
share a similar background to myself I
would say don't worry you would
definitely find people that are your
people just bring your full self to this
school and you will find your community
here I think we're in this really
special moment in time where Asian
Excellence is being celebrated on a
truly global scale natur exciting for
someone like me who grew up thinking
that being Asian-American was what made
me different and should be hidden or
muted but coming to the GSB and seeing
how so many Business Leaders embraced
what made them different and that help
them achieve their success really
reinforced for me that my cultural
background is what's given me a
differentiated and unique perspective
and that's my competitive Advantage so
I'm really proud of the immense progress
that the Asian Community has made and I
can't wait to contribute to that
progress moving
[Music]
forward